all right Antoinette and tonight
where'd you grow up are you from
originally was I just coming for you
south central yes and tell me about your
family dear both your parents when you
were kid
um no I didn't just have my mother where
was then um in and out of prison was he
ever in your life um yes what age did
you have your dad around right six or
seven years old he left then so he was
gone after you were six mm-hmm and my
stepdad stepped in and took over in oh
yeah so how was your childhood you said
how was it how was it um rough any you
think it abuse or traumatic events very
okay um I've been through a lot abuse
yeah from from your mom dad stepdad
Rhoda I'm sorry
ro dad you real good yeah um getting
weapons and yeah so uh what kind of kid
with you in high school
hmm what kind of kid were you in high
school um I was I would say I was off
the chain in high school in June re in
high school where drugs part of the
picture
meet yeah weed and ecstasy and now
you're working in Figueroa yes
how long you been doing this uh I've
been working for the one for like six
years
then holder you know seventeen you've
been doing that since you were 11
yeah you know
twelve you you were with a pimp when you
started there um how did you get started
in this at eleven years old
well when I started I was in I was fully
built high I am now and I was real
mature for my age
so so you looked older yes I did last
bar like body and my ten years old
titties as in everything yeah and the
you're accustomed to the guys that would
pick you up were were aware that you
were 11 years old
um no you wouldn't you would give him
the impression you're older
mm-hmm have you have you been arrested
for this yes yeah
what about it's a dangerous lifestyle
yet guys give you a hard time
oh yes plenty plenty of all what kind of
stuff is happen
I'm a demon rate rock jump don't after
aa to get the service yes so your
parents know you're doing this um my
parents I really don't do it anymore at
all did you run away young age I've been
on my own since I was like 12 13 yeah
and so you're in high school right now
I'm not in school at all
had you been to high school um I was in
wrong I'm sorry I said I was enrolled oh
I see if we didn't go no yeah they do
you have kids of your own
no I don't you don't but you're you're
pregnant right now yeah
how far along are you I'm eight months
you're eight months mm-hmm
and you're still working figure out yes
I
the guys that pick you up must know they
must know that you're pregnant
it's hard to hide and guys are ok with
that
yeah you yes they are you have some that
won't pretty you have some that's a
fetish really yes are you do you know
who the dad is no you don't know no was
it one of your customers maybe um I
believe it was one of my customers that
I have been [ __ ] for a while
yeah I'm not using a condom probably
something and happened yeah so how much
money do you make now Oh
today well since I've been pregnant or
before either one you make more than
being pregnant or less um I made more
being pregnant I'm on a good night and
what was a good night
totally since I've been pregnant seven
hundred and then tips yeah have you
heard to the pimp before no never
mm-hm there are drugs a part of your
life no we Nexus e that's it
this is launched I'll get you down
sometimes you get depressed over doing
this gal when you slow business is slow
you business is slow yes I did do you
find that doing this build your you know
it's some kind of self-esteem boost
getting guys that are all attracted to
you and paying you and yes getting a lot
of attention from guys on the street yes
is it is that the attraction you think
for a lot of the girls that do it yes
that's why I continue to do it you think
yeah do you think you're addicted to
this yeah I mean it's something that I
won't stop doing yeah mm-hmm after you
have the baby you'll still do it yeah
and you're gonna keep the baby yes I
want to still be out there working 24
hours a day seven days to support your
family to support me in my child just
you and just you and your baby yes what
was the best time your life
what donis just I mean in general I mean
your your favorite memories in life in
your short life 17 years old just
touching out and touched money I like
money
yeah money makes you happy yes do you
think do you think doing this since
you're 11 years old has changed you
somehow you think you'd be a different
girl if you had gotten a job at a fast
food restaurant or something like that
yes
I would will still one hustle on the
side because I feel like a little gig on
the side like a square job that's not
enough money especially a restaurant so
I was doing a hustle on the side yeah
yeah
if you have you ever had a boyfriend
yeah they got outside of this know
outside of your cousin yeah
because doing this as a as a job kind of
gets in the way of that sometimes yes
yes
the guys have a hard time handling the
fact you're doing this all night
it's either it's a problem with that or
they won't the mini yeah they turn into
your pimp yeah
and I'm not well that's not gonna happen
it's not gonna happen
so if a young girl were considering
doing this what advice would you give
her I will tell you - don't do it in
this day in school and to find another
hustle for for what reasons because it's
dangerous yeah it's dangerous are you
worried about the life of your baby
knowing that her mom or his mom is going
to be doing this every night to make
money yes you could get only could
happen anything could happen yes at some
point you have to think for your child -
yes will you have your family help you
at all with the raising of the baby no
just on your own
what's the craziest thing that's
happened to you since you've been doing
it - sorry no knees yeah Alan had run
out someone's house [ __ ] naked after
I finish your service I didn't I didn't
damn near ended up on crutches in the
hospital after I didn't finish the
service I tried to get out this guy's
car to get your friend seek to grab my
bag and it's mother [ __ ] drove off
insulin 50 truck I'm hanging on the side
of the truck telling him like I just
want my back but as he's driving off
he's dragging me and I didn't win jumped
on the worst times my clients after I
finished your service
yes do you notice
did you notice at some point that the
lines that you'll cross in terms of like
what what you're okay with and what
you're not okay with have changed over
the years
like like like maybe when you started
you say oh I would never do that and
then as time goes on you find yourself
doing those things that you once would
not do anal like that yes are you doing
that now whoa you make more money for
that man mm-hmm
yes so you didn't have much school but
but working the streets all these years
since you're 11 you've got a lot of
street smarts yes well what do you think
you've learned working the street that
has helped you
who are the street yeah I mean like I'm
sure you there's things there's
knowledge that you've gained from
working hold it who not to trust who to
trust I don't my trust level is don't
trust no one your intuition is probably
yes yeah that in I Mike I got smarter
I'm will street smart yeah
what kind of future do you think your
your child will have I mean you're
you're doing a job or you can get
arrested at any night or get our worst
yes and what's our didn't kill exactly
and what's gonna happen your baby if mom
doesn't come home I think about that all
the time I do um I've been thinking
about some a few things that I want to
do after I have the baby but I still
this is still gonna be my hustle you
know cuz it will be hard to get out the
game yeah with what's what's been the
best experience you've had doing this
I really have it I know
i'ma keep it real with you happy it's
just a rough life yes there's no other
option for you that works for you like
flowers like other dye job other jobs or
other careers are there um no because
it's like once you've been doing it so
long it's like what else you know I
always tell myself like if I get a job I
want it to be a good-paying job
to where I don't have to still go hustle
to make ends meet but yeah that's why I
said that I will get a job and still
hustle I'm sorry
I still have my regular customers all
right tonight thank you so much for
talking with me good luck with your baby
and in your future thank you
you